welcome to this video playing
international master em western who is
that I still no I don't think there's an
M Western I would be I think we I had
this discussion earlier in the channel
that I didn't really know who that is ok
some Italian game where he canceled very
early and I always think that this is
kind of dangerous so I'm going for this
for this straight attack you place this
super quickly like its kind of handle
expected or anything ok and let's let's
push and well nine inch five isn't that
how is he covering this because he isn't
no um no who gave one maybe let's just
for one moment think about this again
can I win direct directly here
now almost empty it really is kind quite
terrible but maybe not a direct win and
I'd have 394 and I'm getting to f2 and
then Bishop g4
so we're going to have to now or
anything better even when you try it's
not it's not that that simple I mean
okay i can grab material probably i can
go Queenie to look g4 and just take h4 I
mean yes very little there is very
little that you can do about it I
probably just this home yeah that's not
bad preparing lon canceling a queen f6
castles long and go from there
huh 97 I mean Bishop e7 is not going to
work I don't believe it or is it is that
going to work b8 Bishop a6 rugby too naw
don't think so
don't answer ok so the ship f3 and night
age 31 night h3 immediately
I don't see a wind actually okay let's
do it like that that was dangerous
anyway but I thought there should be
something better I can take de five
actually okay we'll gauge for roo cage
while threatening made it's kind of
funny okay I can have one asking f1 now
what
now what I have to move the Queen but
where exactly huh I mean okay i can
check first take there and then move the
Queen probably two is six just two is
six it's not going to work so I have to
do this first which is kind of a shame
hmm I'm not threatening now to take on
b7 for Quincy for what a mess what a
damn mess I'm not really threatening it
I believe okay um my chick c-4 would be
good but I don't get that in time money
yeah Hey and I just six it not a lot
doesn't really he'll eat too much
probably ah screw that up badly
yeah I did really believe he can take on
b7 on lasix and if it is very it's very
cheeky to take that but it probably
works check so let's let's let's really
take stock here what is happening I'm in
some pawns down Ice King is still a bit
shaky but it's not really much that I'm
threatening this is the big problem take
you for not working this is for Luke e7
just covering f7
yeah I know that it's probably not
working but non what stuff doesn't help
anymore maybe you can just push the
apron okay this F 7 + f5 hanging okay
check check
still not entirely simple and his King
being so weak check check check No how
lucky can you be a blunder in this
bloody Paulette pre-move shoot check
check check check yeah check button for
the stupid way to use a game for if it's
on time Wow and he blunders the Queen
back out pen wasn't even clear this
position at all now i just have 11
seconds amazing what would interest me
more how can i end this nonsense here
because black is just completely winning
i mean this is this allowing all this
it's just totally terrible and why not
taking with the rook is beyond me and it
was the whole idea of rookie one I
thought but ok i bleep like just wins
straight away what is this minus what is
this man is one just minus one that's
kind actually ok so this is just just
over actually how did I screw it up yeah
9797 I really thought ok nobody would
take on b7 but ok of course they do if
you are completely busted you have to do
this okay the winner is just this too
simple and then root G for h4 I guess
just just a flat-out win and this is now
not clear at all engine gives 000
with 96 but hmm nigeria interesting I
didn't think of this at all this is this
is winning straight away as White's King
is really collapsing so that does not
work the engine gives each five and says
this is a draw a smooth
now can i connect anymore of course but
and this is not working because this is
protected so then this was very
interesting how can white out is why
draw now the engine also gives king of
one okay that's it's a bit yeah that's
interesting but just rolled out not
enough here it's funny that the engine
justice says 0.6 so despite the material
problems things are not as as easy we're
even could have just taken which I
didn't think of it all because the
bishop has very little but it can you
and here this is a line now this is all
of a sudden equal material oh ok I
didn't think of trading in the Queen IAM
and check ok now white should win check
yeah we didn't bother to to find any
good moves you just blundered the Queen
and you are check the real Chan
awkwardness is that here i blundered
this this pawn you have justice and
promotes and I'm winning this with seven
seconds that's just idiotic anyway
thanks for watching